hi I'm Franklin I've lived in a lot of
different places my family is always on
the
[Music]
move this was it our new town do you
want to have excuse me making new
friends can be
hard I'm Franklin Armstrong my name is
Charlie
Brown the big Soapbox Derby race is
Coming to Town the winning team gets a
trophy and free pizza for a whole year
what do you think Charlie Brown partners
[Music]
Partners hey Franklin what kind of music
do you like The Godfather of Soul James
Brown you're not related are you I don't
believe
so my grandpa always says you got to
want it to get it let's see what we can
really
do friendships not perfect but we can
get through the rough spots
together best friend is someone that you
can totally
trust that always has your
[Music]
back hey Franklin we saved you a seat
over here you know you found your home
when you're surrounded by good
friends